you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme part of the hs2 rail link is
scrapped as the government downgrades
plans in the north
prince charles uses his trip to egypt to
send a message to outgoing and incoming
cop presidents about the climate crisis
and a state of emergency is called in
canada because of torrential rain and
flood water
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those who are coming up
with solutions tonight's top story it
promised to cut emissions and link the
north to the south but today the
government confirmed the controversial
hs2 rail link will no longer go all the
way to leeds instead stopping in the
east midlands leaders in the north have
called the changes to the plan a
betrayal but the transport secretary
said a faster service will be provided
in the 96 million pound investment
including improvements to the existing
line but as the uk tries to achieve its
promise of net zero by 2050 rail travel
is essential to reducing those carbon
emissions and its divided opinion well
the announcement today confirmed the hs2
eastern leg will be scrapped meaning
leads will no longer be connected to the
birmingham interchange instead stopping
in the east midlands now let's take a
look at what environmental difference
that could make
well to reach leads from birmingham by
car takes an average of two hours and
produces around 22.33 kilograms of
carbon emissions or co2e per journey
a current train journey takes between 2
hours and 23 minutes and up to 3 hours
47 minutes and produces 6.43 kilograms
of carbon emissions almost three times
less than the car journey now the
scrapped hs2 leg would have cut train
journey times between birmingham and
leeds by over an hour the government
claims hs2 journeys produce as little as
8 grams of carbon emissions per person
per kilometer so using that figure we've
calculated for this trip it would create
1.2 kilograms of carbon emissions so
looking at all of that together you can
see just how each type of travel can
significantly affect the carbon
emissions produced on the same journey
a lot of people say well look what we
should do is carve huge new
railways through virgin territory
smashing through unsupported countryside
and villages and and do it all all of us
now the problem with that is those those
extra high speed lines take decades
and they don't deliver the commuter
benefits that i'm talking about we will
eventually do them and we're building
more than 100 miles
the prime minister there speaking a bit
earlier sky's becky cottrell is at leeds
train station
the government is saying that these new
plans will double capacity between
manchester and leeds and tribble
capacity uh between liverpool and
manchester uh they've also said it will
mean that slaves of unspoiled
countryside won't have to be plowed
through in order to build new railways
however there is confusion up here in
the north about these capacity claims i
just spoke to tracy brabin who is the
west yorkshire man she said well hang on
a second if lees and bradford aren't
included in hs2 they aren't included in
this interconnected transparent line
that has been promised then how is
capacity going to be greatly increased
for people here and if there isn't that
incentive to get on trains to have
faster and more reliable services then
how can they be expected to ditch their
cars now with transport being the
biggest contributor to carbon emissions
in the uk a greener solution does have
to be found and hs2 has said that it
will be more carbon efficient than
conventional trains but there is a sense
here in the north that not only are they
being left behind in terms of their
green ambitions but also in terms of
becoming that big uh powerhouse of
business
well the government hopes things like
investment in rail will help the uk
achieve net zero which means reducing
emissions let's take a look at what's
happening globally then on our data
dashboard this shows the global co2
emissions and as you can see that number
ticking up all the time here is the
power mix in great britain at the moment
gas makes up 37.8
coal is at 2.8 percent today renewables
36.9 and nuclear on 13
well in some of today's other climate
news the number of people who've died in
floods in canada is sadly expected to
rise after the country announced a state
of emergency one death has been
confirmed so far and at least three
people are missing after torrential rain
caused by a so-called atmospheric river
led to mudslides that destroyed roads
and homes a month's worth of rain fell
in two days in what's been described as
a once in a 500 year event which has
also affected towns in the u.s state of
washington
an eco-activist jailed for obstructing
the m25 with insulate britain says she
will go on hunger strike in prison nine
members of the group were sentenced to
between three and six months for
breaching an injunction designed to stop
protesters blocking roads emma smarts
says she's proud of her actions saying
cutting missions
by insulating homes will save lives
a fire has burned through 300 tons of
rubbish at a recycling centre in
wiltshire the fire is now under control
but residents have been advised to stay
indoors to avoid breathing in the smoke
from the blaze
cattle on ireland's west coast are being
fed seaweed which can reduce the amount
of climate warming methane they produce
ireland's per capita output of methane
is the highest in the eu but researchers
believe seaweed can lower ireland's
emissions and contribute to the
country's pledge to cut global output of
methane by 30 percent by 2030.
millions of people around the world are
already being affected by the impacts of
climate change and women are often
disproportionately impacted in a
community in senegal access to family
planning services helps women combine
looking after their families with
working to restore their local
environment here's the latest in our
series of climate diaries
[Music]
m
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
the prince of wales and duchess of
cornwall have joined the next leg of
their royal tour arriving in egypt today
which of course is the home of the next
u.n climate summit cop 27.
as incoming and outgoing presidents of
the um climate side call
i i hope it is more now apparent
that we have to be the custodians
of a truth our ancestors understood so
well
that we are
in actual fair part of the national
world not separate from it
and above all it is our duty to do all
in our power
to protect nature
rather than testing her to literal
destruction
for those who prefer to think in less
philosophical and theological terms i
offer a simple statistic
nature is estimated to contribute
estimated to contribute some
125 trillion a year
to the global economy
that is more
than the annual gdp of this entire
purpose
our obligation could not therefore be
cured
what then should we
as citizens or as leaders do
to hawk and reverse friendship
do stay with us coming up after this
short break i'll be joined by lecturer
in international relations jen allen and
the co-founder of the cop 26 climate
action plan chidi ot obihara and we'll
be discussing whether an effective
public transport system is crucial if
the uk wants to reach net zero speaking
to them in a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that sheet of flames
and it's moving this way
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
the people here are praying
quietly to themselves
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
[Music]
they're becoming very sensitive
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
every time they touch and they spray
sprayed spray
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
i can't imagine
how much plastic
is lying at the bottom of this huge lake
i'm tom cheshire and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing
we help you understand the world with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back just before the break we
hear from prince charles who's on a tour
of egypt and he's been speaking about
green issues let's join our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills she's in
cairo with them it was very interesting
rhiannon wasn't it that the prince of
wales concentrated the whole of his
speech on the environment
[Music]
i think in recent weeks we have often
seen him take to the stage especially
around cop 26 to hammer home that
message that we have to act now on the
climate crisis but what an incredible
stage he had today to make that message
and it was an incredibly apt one twofold
first of all of course the uk has just
concluded cop 26 but is now handing over
the baton to egypt who will host cop 27
when it comes to the ongoing
negotiations
around what the world can do to be more
environmentally friendly but also i
think standing there amongst the
pyramids he was trying to stress using
those amazing ancient artifacts saying
look even places like this are under
threat because of things like high
temperatures because of extreme winds
and floods also egypt very much at the
center of the crisis as well because of
biodiversity loss and rising sea levels
so for him at least this was an area
where he could really make his point but
also i think what is quite turning is
yes in recent weeks he's talked a great
deal about the future about how business
and governments need to work together
but he is also a deeply traditional man
i think he feels that we have lost sight
of many of the essential values which
could help to protect nature in that
speech he said we need to rediscover a
sense of the sacred by learning to live
within the bounds of nature rather than
thinking we can ignore them and for him
this was a really important message yes
a rallying call to egypt as they in the
future will host cop27 but also that
pick those pictures of him and camilla
alongside the pyramids he knows they
will go right around the world so again
this was a global message that he was
desperate to get out there
okay very interesting rihanna and many
thanks rhiannon in cairo for us
okay let's get straight into discussing
the climate issues of the day tonight
with lecturer in international relations
at cardiff university jen allen and
extinction rebellion activist and
co-founder of the cop 26 climate action
plan chidi oti obihara there they both
are and we're going to discuss the
cancellation of part of the high-speed
rail network today it's provoked strong
reaction hasn't it among those who were
looking forward to faster transport
links and an efficient public transport
system is crucial of course if the uk is
to reach its emissions targets well
let's get the reaction of jen uh first
of all um the hs2 eastern leg being
scrapped it really is a blow isn't it to
achieving a low
carbon very efficient public transport
network
well it depends on what happens next
because right now it's tough to see how
the actions of the government actually
will get us to net zero there's only
about two billion for walking and
cycling
seven for public transport and so with
this cancellation
maybe existing lines could be upgraded
in a way to get people where they need
to be faster and more reliably
but if that doesn't happen then yeah
it's not going to help us hit net zero
in any way yeah and that's exactly what
the government's argument is isn't it
chidi that actually what they can do is
upgrade spend a bit more money on the
existing line rather than throwing
billions at hs2
you're absolutely right the reversal of
the beaching cuts is part of the process
we're going through right now i think
the challenge for trying to understand
what's going on with hs2
is that we're treating you know
transport to the north of england that's
a problem that has to be solved rather
than looking at the opportunities that
are there that we can expand on
so the cancellation that we've seen
has to have a review of what the actual
costs and benefits are we don't know
what the biodiversity costs to that leg
were we don't know how this changes that
equation
the whole hs2 project runs on the
supposition that it's uh it reduces the
cost of carbon travel to eight grams per
person per mile now it's eight times
that if you go by car
and it's about 20 times that if you fly
so hs2 does have benefits that it
provides whether or not this rule change
is a net cost or net benefit is
something we don't yet know
of course generally the other argument
is that if you're going to build new
railway lines that causes a huge amount
of damage to the environment and to the
countryside
yeah and there are a few things that
were a bit strange with some of the hs2
builds that was happening like digging
up an entire ecosystem and saying we can
replant it and it'll be fine we can
transplant an entire ancient woodland
which doesn't have a lot of
success stories out there
so you know
as we were saying there's a lot of
uncertainties here so now we're dealing
with things that we know we know what
the existing links are we know how they
have to be approved but that can't
really be well planned from london
so putting money into councils into
communities they know who needs to get
where where people work where people
live and where people play
they're the ones best place to figure
out efficient transit
okay very interesting well let's talk
cash next because one big announcement
you'll remember at cop was from the
former head of the bank of england mark
carney he announced 450 financial firms
would use 130 trillion dollars huge
amount of money to invest in areas
helping to achieve
net zero this is what he had to say up
in glasgow chile you've been working on
a project to stop funding for new fossil
fuels is this what mark carney's plan is
partly about
it isn't specified yet but it's an
excellent start so at the cop26 crime
reaction plan the group i co-founded
over six months ago we've been talking
for a very long time about how important
it is to draw a line under further
investments in fossil fuels
effectively we were asking for a debate
to be had at cop26 asking global leaders
to stop financing new fossil fuels you
can't claim to be in transition if
you're still growing the fossil fuel
industry what mark carney's group has
done is spectacular they've managed to
gather 450 of the world's largest
organizations financial financial
organizations who have a net combined uh
asset base of over 130 trillion dollars
and these firms have effectively agreed
not to support any new fossil fuel
investments this is a game changer it
sounds fantastic doesn't it but jen is
it transparent do you think who's going
to monitor this
oh i'd love to be kind to my fellow
canadian mark carney but it's tough to
know i mean they're saying net zero by
2050 and there's no short-term plans in
here that tell us how they're going to
get there there's no plans to report
back so we know exactly where that money
is going and there isn't a lot of detail
around what they're counting as climate
finance
so we don't know what's going to happen
yet it's it's a long-term promise and
without short-term plans to get us there
we won't know if we hit it until 2050.
which is too late yeah it's a long way
off um chidi the private sector then
managing to pivot 130 trillion dollars
which is just a huge amount of money but
governments around the world still
struggling to find that 100 billion
which is a lot smaller a year for
vulnerable countries
that's an exceptionally good question
and just to support what jen was just
saying the plans are not smart they're
not specific measurable accurate
relevant time related that's because
they're new um they haven't been adopted
by cop but this starts the conversation
and you're absolutely right um being
able to have funds available for for
loss and adaptation is an absolutely
essential uh a step that has to be taken
the hundred billion that was promised
hasn't been reached but it's so much
lower than where we need to be so again
at the conference exchange plan we did
our numbers and we came up with 2.2
trillion per annum and luckily people
like mark carney have come out and said
that number is even too low we need to
go even further so i think we're
actually in a stage of negotiations
where 2050 will be challenged we need
2030. funds will become available both
from government and from private sector
this is the beginning of a really
interesting change we are potentially
turning the titanic around so yes i'll
absolutely admit this is just a start
but it's an exciting one
okay uh good to end on some positivity
there but just before we go jen i want
to bring in the thoughts of sarah jane
ahmed she's a climate finance advisor
for vulnerable countries that you can
see what she had to say at cop she said
the message coming out of this cop is
every country for themselves now that is
pretty damning jen i mean would you
agree with that
yeah finance at the last cop was really
difficult the fact that developed
countries couldn't make good on a
ten-year-old promise for a hundred
billion just dismantled any trust that
there was between countries
and the fact that they couldn't talk
about finance for the permanent effects
of climate change for permanent losses
and damages
that means that there was no hope really
for developing countries feel like
they're being supported they're being
told don't develop with fossil fuels but
we're not going to provide you support
for another path oh and all those
climate damages you're currently
experiencing there's no money for that
either
so yeah i could see why a lot of
developing country delegates left
thinking they're in it for themselves
kitty
is absolutely right i mean that the
whole idea of making progress on this is
we do so international solidarity
the context of doing this is that up
until this cop for 25 cops before this
we couldn't even get the words fossil
fuels entered into the you know the
summary for policymakers we've changed
that and we now actually have a private
sector that wants to help the
governments who have absolutely failed
on their commitments to deal with the
rights that they they claim they've
acquired but if we live in a world in
which we're going to make transition
quickly we have to actually fund it so
the idea that mark carney can corral the
private sector to help governments is
something we have to welcome and push
forward together on okay we must leave
it there thanks very much both of you
chidi oti obi hara jen allen always good
to get your thoughts thank you very much
indeed and that's it from us for today
on tomorrow's show i'll be joined by
emily shukba climate scientist and the
director of cambridge zero and michael
jacobs who's professor of political
economy at sheffield university
discussing all the big climate stories
of the day of course and that's it do
stay tuned coming up next we'll have all
the very latest from you on the cricket
situation with azim rafiq who's been
speaking to mps